europa hat seine glaubenskriege
überwunden
so glaubten wir zumindest in der
religion ja in der medizin eher nein
neuestes beispiel das für und wider von
impfen aktuell vor dem hintergrund des
ausbruchs von masern hier in der
bundeshauptstadt berlin maß an alarm
glauben glaubenskrieg uns impfen
folglich liebe zuschauer heute das thema
der phoenix runde willkommen bei uns
meine gäste mario czaja der cdu senator
für gesundheit und soziales in berlin
bei uns ist hendrik ihr arzt sie sind
heilpraktikerin
sie bilden auch nachwuchs außen sie
haben in ihrem bereich vor allen dingen
mit impfschäden mit der heilung von
impfschäden zu tun
hans tolzin es bei uns freier journalist
und herausgeber der impfkritischen
zeitschrift in freeport und martin
terhardt kinderarzt mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission muss man noch
erklären das ist ein unabhängiges
expertengremium wird vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium berufen
mitglieder sind experten aus
wissenschaft und forschung aus dem
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst und von
niedergelassenen ärzten und sie gehören
auch zur nationalen verifizierung für
die elimination also die ausmerzung von
masern und röteln hat scharia als
gesundheitssenator hier in berlin ist ja
im moment besonders betroffen
was gibt es neues aber die neuesten
stand der maße epidemie in berlin stand
heute wir haben seit der 41
kalenderwoche letzten jahres diesen
ausbruch in berlin von masern leider
erleben müssen
im jahr 2015 sind die zahlen dann noch
mal stärker gestiegen als in den ersten
wochen dieses jahres und wir sind jetzt
bei etwas mehr als 630 masern kranken in
berlin die gemeldet wurden und überragt
damit weit alle anderen bundesländer
wohl das meistens im einstelligen
bereich im moment ist warum das in
berlin so ist darüber müssen wir
vielleicht auch noch reden hat holz ihn
ist impfen
denn generell teufelszeug
generell würde ich jetzt das so nicht
nicht sagen es kommt alt auf den glauben
an wie sie an gespielt haben als er mich
ist es eine frage
als jemand der selbst kinder hat und vor
der entscheidung stand wenn meine kinder
sind jetzt erwachsen ist es die frage
gibt es eine wirksamkeit die mich
überzeugt ist dass im risiko
kalkulierbar und wie sieht es mit
alternativen aus gibt es alternativen
oder nicht und ich bin einfach bei der
prüfung diese der fakten die mir
vorliegen
zu der überzeugung gekommen dass es mich
nicht überzeugt ja also wenn sie mich
jetzt wenn ich jetzt mal auf die wirkung
ganz kurz eingehen darf vielleicht wenn
wir das in der in der sendung dann
selbst noch mal sehr tief weil sie sagen
sie sind nicht überzeugt von dem kartell
hat jetzt ist noch ein anderer begriff
gefragt glauben ist eine glaubenssache
für herrn tolzin die impfbefürworter zu
den sie ja gehören leisten die einfach
zu wenig überzeugungsarbeit noch um die
menschen von impfung zu überzeugen der
notwendigkeit sieht so aus dass wir
immer noch nicht genug um genügend
überzeugungsarbeit geleistet haben aber
halt wir tun unser bestes und wir sind
selber überzeugt nicht nur wir glauben
nicht nur wir wissen auch dass impfungen
wirken und das hier halt auch
verträglich und sicher genug sind um das
der bevölkerung zu empfehlen dass es ja
die aufgabe der ständigen impfkommission
das abzuwägen dafür wälzen wir genug
wissenschaft die es weltweit dazu gibt
und insofern ist das sicherlich gut
mittlerweile begründet die empfehlungen
die die stiko abgibt aber die
bevölkerung dann zu überzeugen dass das
auch die richtige entscheidung ist das
wird zunehmend schwieriger weil halt in
der bevölkerung auch viele andere
strömungen da sind die generell der
schulmedizin rationalen medizin
misstrauen der arzt warum hat das thema
sitzende käse die wir aufgestellt haben
warum hat dieses thema die dimension
eines glaubenskrieges angenommen
ich denke weil die faktenlage auf beiden
seiten letztlich für den das elternteil
oder denjenigen der sich da mit dieser
entscheidung auseinandersetzen muss
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist also man
kann das glauben oder auch nicht wir
wissen diesen berühmten spruch
statistiken glaube ich nur dich selbst
gefälscht habe das ist nicht mehr
wahrnehmbar ich muss mich also auf
quellen verlassen
die aber eben durch manche erfahrungen
die so im raum stehen dann doch in frage
gestellt werden
zum beispiel wenn jetzt gerade bei den
masern
ja wir einfach auch davon ausgehen
müssen dass es dunkelziffern gibt sowohl
was erkrankung angeht was auch als
impfschaden fall gemeldet wird es
entspricht auch nicht unbedingt dem was
real ist es gibt auch dunkelziffern und
ich denke dass die menschen etwas
brauchen was für sie wirklich real
greifbar ist und dass dieser zahlen
krieg schwer fassbar und dann verlässt
man sich vielleicht doch eher auf
erfahrungen in denen man teil hat vom
nachbarn von menschen die man kennt von
menschen die man trifft und die
widersprechen auf dem was an den
offiziellen statistiken verbreitet wir
glauben sagt man ja auch der mann gerade
auch ein stichwort mit statistiken ein
sprichwort mit statistiken zitiert hat
glauben heißt ja auch nicht wissen woran
liegt das woran liegt das hat man auch
fakten ignoriert dass man eigene
überzeugungen hat oder sagt ich glaub
das einfach nicht was ist das was steckt
dahinter
da muss weitere aufklärungsarbeit
geleistet werden das ist richtig sicher
so aber wir haben 30.000 kinder in
berlin
die jedes jahr auf die welt kommen 96
prozent davon lassen ihre erste haben
ihre erste masernimpfung für den
schuleingangsuntersuchungen sehen wir
dass 91 prozent davon die zweite haben
und bei den gemeldeten schäden und damit
meine ich alle und nicht nur die der
masern haben wir im vergangenen jahr in
berlin fünf gemeldete impfschäden gehabt
für alle sachverhalte die es überhaupt
gibt also ich finde da muss man schon
viel an hokuspokus glauben um
solche zahlen 30.000 kinder die sich die
pro jahr neu auf die welt kommen die
sich zu 96 prozent impfen lassen und
dann 5 5 stehen wenn man die dann noch
im einzelnen sich anschaut stellt man
fest dass da die impfung bei fast keinem
die ursache dafür waren also die impfung
hilft
und es ist ja auch so dass sich die
große mehrheit der gesellschaft
vernünftig verhält und sich impfen lässt
und unsere aufgabe ist halt eben diesen
häufig kursierenden gerüchten dann nimmt
auch entgegen zu wirken denn die
wissenschaft spricht sehr deutliche
sprache und ich glaube das was frau arzt
sie erzählt ich glaube das kann man der
familie deren kind gerade gestorben ist
weil sie die impfung nicht vorgenommen
hat so nicht erklären
also bei 30.000 neugeborenen und fünf
nachgewiesenen impfschäden sieht man das
mit der mit den impfungen den
vorbehalten gegen über die impfung nicht
etwas zu kritisch gut die frage ist ja
woher wissen wir dass die impfung eine
wirksamkeit hat wenn er der hat sagt er
glaubt nicht er weiß dann ist das für
ihn klar aber für mich wenn ich jetzt
als vater oder als mutter vor einer
entscheidung stehe wie wie komme ich
dazu einer klarheit
ja das war für mich damals als ich
angefangen habe mich mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen auch wirklich nicht ganz
einfach ja weil da die wirklich die
argumente so gegeneinander standen und
wann immer ich mich mit eltern auf
seminaren und vorträgen unterhalten über
die frage woher weiß ich denn das sind
impfstoff wirksam ist
dann kommen wir an häme auf die formel
wirksamkeit ist der beweis dass geimpfte
gegenüber ungeimpften einen deutlichen
gesundheitlichen vorteil haben und das
bedeutet dass man das eigentlich nur in
form von doppelblinden placebo studien
nachweisen kann
und solche studien werden die
funktionieren doppelblinde placebo
studien was das genau ist ja das heißt
eine gruppe von fast 1000 kinder waren
mit wird geimpft mit den impfstoff die
andere gruppe 1000 kinder werden mit
einem placebo kämpft das heißt ohne
wirkungslosen scheinimpfstoff der weder
eine wirkung noch
eine nebenwirkung hat und dem
placebo-effekt auszuschalten und so eine
studie die ordentlich durchgeführt würde
würde mich könnte mich möglicherweise
sogar noch neue medikamente immer
getestet das ist bei den impfstoffen
nicht der fall
ich mein hut der hat würden wir das
sicherlich bestätigen es gibt da keinen
einzigen impfstoff auf dem deutschen
markt der eine ordentliche
plazebo-kontrollierte doppelblindstudie
vorweisen kann ich nicht bestätigen das
ist natürlich so die neuen bedingungen
gehen die impfstoffe zugelassen werden
können das ist ja weltweit und
europaweit das zulassungsverfahren
stattfinden sehen vor dass randomisierte
kontrollierte auch placebokontrollierte
studien stattfinden wo man halt ein
scheinmedikament mit dem medikament als
mit dem tatsächlichen impfstoff
vergleichen muss die letzten impfstoffe
die auf den markt gekommen sind also zum
beispiel der rotavirus impfstoff ist ein
groß angelegten studien so überprüft
worden mit über 60.000 probanden und hat
da ist die wirksamkeit geprüft worden
und die früheren zulassungsstudien war
nicht ganz so aufwendig deswegen gibt es
für viele ältere impfstoffe nicht so
aufwendige studien dass auch einer der
gründe warum neue impfstoffe teuer
werden
aber halt wir haben zu allen impfstoffen
die es gibt die es jetzt jetzt
angewendet werden sehr zuverlässige
metaanalysen also das heißt
zusammenfassung von studien nach
hochrangigen kriterien der
evidenzbasierten medizin die gerade die
masern in die wirksamkeit des masern und
röteln impfstoffes nachgewiesen haben
cochran studie aus 2012 die wird auch
als zehn wahrscheinlich kennen
jedenfalls da wird die wirksamkeit auch
die sicherheit des impfstoffes sehr gut
beschrieben für die einzelnen impfstoffe
die auf der welt unterschiedlich
verwendet werde ich mal eine frage
stellen wenn sie vor allem im schatten
der handel wie muss man sich denn
vorstellen da kommt jemand zu ihnen die
in die praxis und vermutet dass einen
impfschaden erlitten hat wie kriegen sie
das raus wie macht sich das bei den
menschen bemerkbar wie erkennen sie dass
wie verhält sich dieser mensch welchen
schaden hat er erlebt
das ist ganz unterschiedlich manche
haben schon einen verdacht manche haben
noch nicht mal einer blassen vorstellung
davon dass überhaupt eine impfung bei
den bei der verursachung der beschwerden
im spiel ist das ergibt sich dann weil
man in der klassischen homöopathie sehr
aufwendig
andere lesen macht die sehr viel zeit
beanspruchen untersuchungen wo auch
zeitlich aufgestellt wird wann hat was
in diesem leben stattgefunden wann ist
welche krankheit welche impfung gewesen
diesen aufwand treibt normalerweise ein
normaler niedergelassener arzt nicht
kann ja gar nicht in dem zeitfenster was
ihm bleibt und da ergeben sich dann
manchmal diese zuordnung und der patient
selbst darüber erstaunt und wenn er dann
feststellt dass ich das sogar wiederholt
bei der wiederholungs impfung kurz
danach was ihm gar nicht bewusst war
weil er sich da überhaupt nicht darauf
fokussiert hat und man vielleicht drei
vier wochen einer impfung auch gar nicht
mehr daran denkt dass das vielleicht bei
mir im zusammenhang stehen könnte das
gibt es oft an überraschungseffekte weil
man das dann plötzlich mal im zahlen
strahl sieht des lebens und dann
plötzlich denkt oh das ist mir gar nicht
aufgefallen ich hatte mal einen hund in
behandlung der hat seine analysen ups es
immer nach einer tollwutimpfung und die
besitzer haben das gar nicht realisiert
erst als wir dann die die daten der
erkrankung und behandlung und tier auf
den mensch schlüsse ziehen was die
reaktion angeht naja ich kann jetzt
nicht von der tollwutimpfung am tier auf
die impfung menschen schließen das nicht
aber ich kann schon sehen dass auch
tiere durchaus mit impfstoffen nicht
immer nur in die positive richtung sind
ja immer der diskussion im bereich der
glaubensfragen hat schreien dann könnte
man ja dem voran stellt die frage wer
hat eigentlich welche verantwortung
welche verantwortung spielt bei der
frage impfen ja oder nein eine rolle
jeden einzelnen betrachtet eltern lehrer
ärzte politiker wer hat welche
verantwortung in dieser frage wir alle
haben die verantwortung einen
immunschutz zu haben damit wir nicht
über träger dieser krankheit für jene
werden die ein schwaches immunsystem
haben bzw noch nicht geimpft werden
können wie kleinstkinder oder menschen
mit einer immunschwäche ist es unter
anderem die aufgabe von kita erzieherin
dass sie im impfschutz haben damit sie
nicht überträger werden
kleine kinder die möglicherweise auch
noch nicht die zweite impfung haben wir
eltern haben eine verantwortung für
unsere kinder und die stadt hat die
verantwortung für das impfen zu werben
die ständige impfkommission gibt dafür
empfehlungen und diesen empfehlungen
daneben auch die notwendige
öffentlichkeit zu geben und so traurig
dieser fall derzeitig ist von dem toten
anderthalbjährigen jungen in berlin
so sehen wir doch das sehr sehr viele
ihre impfbücher suchen nachschauen ob
sie einen impfschutz haben dass uns die
arztpraxen sei wir haben derzeit ich
besonders viele die kommen und wollen
ihren impfschutz überprüfen lassen
die große große mehrheit der
gesellschaft verhält sich in dieser
frage ja verantwortungsbewusst aber am
ende ist es die kleine gruppe derer die
ungeimpft sind die dazu führen dass es
zu einer solchen epidemie kommen wir
jetzt und dann am ende eben auch kinder
sterben die selber sich nicht schützen
aber ich glaube zwischen 80 und 90
prozent der kinder sind ausreichend
geimpft 90 93 bis 95 glaube ich sein um
eine solche richtig einzuhegen dahinter
steckt ja auch bei denen die nicht
geimpft sind also auch eine eine kleine
prozentzahl macht er da schon viel
aussagen sind eine kleine minderheit ist
ein manche sagen ja sogar eine
irrationale angst vor dem impfen auch
vor der schulmedizin
woher kommt das gibt es dafür
nachvollziehbare gründe dass schulen
medizin sie haben es gerade selbst ja
schon erwähnt so oft ja im fokus im
fadenkreuz steht
ich denke da ist der begriff
glaubenskrieg schon ganz gut gewählt das
sind sicherlich eher
lebensphilosophische sichtweisen mainz
verschwörungstheorien esoterischer
lebensstil anthroposophische denkweise
um eur partie das sind so die stichworte
die halt vieles an der imw medizin und
auch an der anderen schulmedizin
anzweifeln und eigene wege gehen und
auch das was vor ort eben gesagt hat das
ist ein gutes beispiel dafür
tollwutimpfung bei einem hund und
datenanalyse nachts ass der länder immer
wieder schlimmer wird aber den analysen
ups hatte er vorher schon
der wird nur durch die impfungen immer
wieder aktiviert weil die impfung
natürlich das immunsystem stimuliert und
auch das immunsystem ablenkt und dann
halt solche prozesse
vorkommen auch im menschen passiert so
etwas die impfung greift natürlich ins
immunsystem des kindes und das erwachsen
der geimpft wird ein unterlaufen
prozesse ab die auch halt neben dem imf
erfolg stattfinden das wissen wir die
kinder haben fieber
der körper muss was tun um halt die
abwehrstoffe zu bilden wir bilden die
wir wollen dass er sie bildet sofern das
sind kann ihn fäden das sind
nebenwirkungen jede medizinische
maßnahmen auch eine impfung hat eine
wirkung und nebenwirkung die müssen wir
in kauf nehmen weil sie harmloser ist
als die erkrankung die eine komplikation
haben aber hier noch was anderes zu
ihren zahlen nehmen dann ist mir ganz
wichtig wir haben gute zahlen
mittlerweile bei den kleinen kindern
wenn sie die schule kommen
wir müssten sie eigentlich mit zwei
jahren haben da sind wir schlecht wir
sind aber noch viel viel schlechter bei
den jugendlichen und bei den jungen
erwachsenen da sind wir ganz weit
entfernt von den 95 prozent und diese
gruppe immer viel schlechter erreichen
sie sagen sie sind bei den kindern und
den zahlen gut aber sehen wir nur die
zahlen oder sehen wir auch die kinder
und wenn wir die kinder sehen und
vergleichen die in der praxis sehe die
regelmäßig geimpft werden und welche
erkrankungshäufigkeit die haben und wie
die sich so durch die kindergarten- und
schulzeit schleppen und kinder sehe die
nicht geimpft sind aber gut
homöopathisch eingestellt dann sehe ich
da einen signifikanten unterschied in
der ganzen präsenz gegenüber krankheiten
in der präsenz des immunsystems und in
der abwehr lage gegenüber
krankheitskeimen dass es eine sehr
selektive sicht das liegt in der natur
der sache in dem was sie für eine sorte
von betreuung betreiben sie sehen halt
nur die die zu ihnen kommen die weit
größere mehrheit kommt halt in unsere
praxen und die studien gemacht werden in
der verträglichkeit von impfstoffen in
impfkomplikationen wird halt von der
überwachungsbehörde in deutschland und
in europa durchgeführt in deutschland
vom paul-ehrlich-institut wo ich alles
was dazu sind komplikationen und
impfschäden die passiv oder aktiv
gemeldet werden überprüft werden und hat
sehr gut wissenschaftlich aufgearbeitet
werden weil das auch ein
verantwortlicher aufgabe des staates ist
dafür sorgen dass diese maßnahme die bei
gesunden menschen und kindern
vorgenommen wird auch sicher ist und
diese verantwortung übernimmt der staat
und ich wehre mich auch immer hingegen
dieses misstrauen das im prinzip
dahinter steht dass die person die da
verantwortung tragen in unserem system
tatsächlich es wagen würden
ganz bewusst diese risiken und gefahren
in kauf zu nehmen den kinder ausgesetzt
werden lassen eltern fragen haben nicht
beantworten können
aber wenn ich mal sagen da auf dem stoff
sicherheit zur wirksamkeit der die auch
noch einiges aber das paul ehrlich
institut ist in deutschland für die
zulassung von impfstoffen und für die
impfstoff sicherheit zuständig hat
selbst im bundesgesundheitsblatt
eingeräumt die häufigkeit von schweren
nebenwirkungen von schweren und
schwersten nebenwirkungen ist unbekannt
kann nicht kann kann genannt werden
dann könnte sich doch hier nicht sich
nicht hinsetzen und sagen die impfstoffe
sind sicher sie müssen sagen genau sagen
was sie damit meinen
der grund dafür dass die dass das im das
ist eigentlich eigentliche frage ist das
impfstoff risiko kalkulierbar
statistisch zumindest und wenn
statistisch kalkulierbar ist dann kann
ich abwägen zwischen nutzen und risiken
ja die zulassungsstudien sind zu klein
es stimmt eben nicht was sie hier
behaupten das ist ordentliche
placebokontrollierten doppelblindstudien
gibt ich habe das paul-ehrlich-institut
da auch danach gefragt kann ich dazu
kommen aber jetzt nochmal zu den stoff
sicherheit die impfstoff studien sind zu
klein um seltenere schwere und schwerste
nebenwirkungen überhaupt erfassen zu
können
das meldesystem für impfkomplikationen
liegt völlig danieder das lesen sie im
bundesgesundheits hat was das
paul-ehrlich-institut darüber schreiben
schutzgesetz werden die sind in der lage
ehrlich institut geschrieben die
dunkelziffer ist noch nicht einmal
abzuschätzen
wenn ich der chef vom
paul-ehrlich-institut wäre und ich wäre
zuständig für die sicherheit von
impfstoffen ja dann würde ich mal gucken
wo liege ich überhaupt mit den meldungen
wenn etwa 2000 meldungen im jahr
einkommen in deutschland ja wo liegt
denn also es gibt ein einmal hat das
paul ehrlich institut eine arbeit
zitiert von lasag et al
wer hat geschätzt maximal fünf prozent
aller komplikationen werden
meldet das heißt wir müssten diese 2000
im jahr mit 20 multiplizieren sie alle
vermutungen die sie jetzt sagen wie ich
akzeptieren frage richtig stellen und
dann bringt es auch den eltern die zu
schauen etwas ich stehe jetzt eine
richtige frage versucht jedenfalls
schulmedizin sagen sie die ist insofern
nicht akzeptabel weil einfach die
nebenwirkungen zu groß sind und die
nachteile sind denn sicher dass die
andere form der medizin ich nenne sie
jetzt mal die an den anthroposophischen
zugang dass der keine nebenwirkungen hat
und dass der den menschen glücklicher
ist woher das zunächst mal um impfungen
und dem masernimpfung und die frage ist
nicht wer kann beweisen dass die
impfstoffe unsicher sind weil damit
haben sich beweislast bei uns eltern ja
das kann noch nicht wirklich sein
sondern die frage ist könnt ihr vom
paul-ehrlich-institut vom von der stiko
zb die 13 todesfälle nach
masernimpfungen die seit 2001 gemeldet
sind ja könnt ihr ausschließen dass es
da ein zusammenhang mit der impfung gibt
das können sie nicht doch eher tolzin
sie haben den artikel ja wahrscheinlich
gelesen
das paul-ehrlich-institut sehr genau
dazu stellung genommen dass jeder
einzelfall geprüft wurde und jeden jedem
einzelfall auch diese zuordnung
vorgenommen wurde
ja aber das geht ja nur wenn man genau
wenn man sagen kann wenn man sagen kann
woran das kind dann gestorben ist das
geht doch auch in dem artikel
das kind das in berlin gestorben ist ja
sie haben bei ihrer ersten pressemeldung
gesagt es hat ist an masern gestorben
hat keine vorerkrankung und jetzt hat
sich das herausgestellte stimmt gar
nicht
der obduktionsbericht sagt ja es ist an
masern gestorben und diese behauptung
ist eine andere ursache hat der behaupte
ja weitgehend relativiert wenn ich die
meines wissens liegt oder lag eine
schwere herzerkrankung vor und bei einer
schweren herzerkrankung greift jedes
fiebert man diesen ärzte und
heilpraktiker sie sind arzt jedes fieber
greift natürlich das herz
anja also die kliniken drehen sich das
so wie sie es brauchen
anfang des anfang des jahres waren die
obduktionspflicht gefälscht hat also
wirklich sie dass menschen seiner
krankenhaus infektionen gestorben
und dann hieß es ja von der klinik ja
die sind nicht an der
krankenhausinfektionen gestorben sondern
dem obduktionsbericht angesprochen in
berlin waren im kind das da neulich
gestorben ist es ist am vergangenen
mittwoch ein kind in der in der charité
gestorben was medizinisch wegen der
rasant behandelt wurde
es ist dann weil es wegen der masern
auch in das krankenhaus cham über das
örtliche gesundheitsamt uns gemeldet
worden als obersten
landesgesundheitsbehörde und da hat das
hat dir ist das gesundheitsamt uns
deutlich gemacht das kind ist an masern
gestorben
neben erkrankungen habe ich mich in der
ersten erklärung überhaupt nicht
geäußert sondern auch deutlich gemacht
die genauen hintergründe wird der
obduktionsbericht zeigen diese
obduktionsbericht ist dann einen tag
später von der charité veröffentlicht
worden
und er sagt das kind hatte einen eben
erkrankung das ist richtig aber die
masse an waren ursächlich für den für
die für den für den ausbruch dieser
neben erkrankung die ursache und das
kind ist an den masern gestorben
im übrigen war sagt genau nach im
übrigen war das ja auch eine obduktion
die nicht durch die charité sondern hier
an dieser stelle durch eine unabhängige
obduktion erfolgt wie das immer der fall
ist und insofern kann man das nachlesen
da gibt es eine erklärung der charité
die auf deren die sie auch noch einmal
präzisiert haben nachdem dann auch
wieder verschwörungstheorien im internet
kursierten dass das höchstwahrscheinlich
irgendwie so hingebogen sei die charité
das noch einmal noch einmal bestätigt
und ich verlasse mich ich bin ja auch
familienvater auf die auf die auf die
medizin und auf die charité und auf das
was auch beispielsweise die ständige
impfkommission empfiehlt und wir sehen
ja auch dass die mehrheit sich der
verantwortung bewusst sind und dass
kinder die
die masern durchlebt haben viel häufiger
schwerste schäden davontragen auch noch
nach zehn oder 15 jahren noch schwere
schäden haben können die ursache dafür
haben dass man die masern durchleben
musste und dass jede menge das was wir
kinder gegen masern völlig ohne
nachwirkungen durch mache ich und in
ihrer immunität sogar stabilisiert
werden sogar chronische krankheiten
danach nicht mehr an
fallen die vorjahr wie neurodermitis zum
beispiel während war es ist ja nicht so
dass alle möglichen leute aus langeweile
sich überlegt haben wie sie den im plan
und die impf ideen der bundesregierung
durch kreuzen können sondern es einfach
da zu ungereimtheiten gekommen ich kann
mich erinnern
ich wurde noch wie viele säuglinge einen
tag nach der geburt mit der bcg impfung
beglückt und diese impfung hat sehr sehr
viele jahre deutschlandweit gewirkt ich
habe was ist das eigentlich das ist die
tuberkulose am ersten tag nach der
geburt also sehr früh moment der
vielleicht auch diskussionswürdig ist
angesichts dessen was wir heutzutage
über immunsystem und den weg des
immunsystems wissen also so früh mit
fremde weiß jemanden zu konfrontieren
ist vielleicht nicht das allerwichtigste
das hat sich dann auch irgendwie gezeigt
aber nicht und da ist der
vertrauensverlust entstanden nicht indem
man irgendwann hingegangen ist noch 40
jahren gesagt hat also irgendwie war das
mit dieser bcg info nicht so das wahre
wir sind zu der überzeugung gekommen
dass die und die schäden aufgetreten
sind und die leute die geimpft wurden
konnten sich dann entsprechend auch
informieren sondern das wurde gar nicht
thematisiert ich persönlich würde zum
beispiel gegen tb c geimpft und habe es
dann
dadurch bekommen also ich habe tbc durch
eine impfung bekommen und also
unmittelbar nach der geburt war nach der
geburt und es gibt da einige fälle es
gibt ja auch masernfälle 17 und dann ist
man hat man den indien festgestellt dass
von den geimpften doch so viele trotzdem
an tbc erkrankt sind das war also dann
offiziell per studie sozusagen
schulmedizinisch festgestellt aber
rohstoffe oder öffentlich nicht nicht
mit verbreitet und dann haben die leute
den impfstoff drin und haben keine
information was das eigentlich in
wallis muss gewartet da wird es sagen
klang es vom markt gezogen und das ist
weder transparent noch in dem sinne
geeignet menschen zu informieren und
mündig zu machen
wie sieht es eigentlich möchten aber
liebe verrat das ist doch genau das
gegenteil sie sehen an diesem beispiel
dass das system der impfstoff
überwachung funktioniert
da hatten wir auch noch größere probleme
mit der tuberkulose die tuberkulose
häufigkeit in deutschland ist zum glück
gesunken und so dass es irgendwann so
war dass die nachteile der impfung
größer waren als die nachteile oder
dieses risiko zu erkranken
und dann muss man natürlich eine
konsequenz ziehen und dann hat
deutschland in grenzen gezogen
wir hätten gerne einen besseren
impfstoff gegen tuberkulose weil wir
großes problem haben mit
multiresistenten tuberkulose
aber die bcg impfung die übrigens keine
tuberkulose aus wird sondern eine bcg
entzündung an der impfstelle mit um das
zu korrigieren war eine komplizierte
impfung die wesentlich mehr in velen und
in komplikation gemacht hat als die
meisten anderen in form genauso wie die
polio schluckimpfung die nebenwirkungen
hatte die in einem risiko standen das
höher war hinterher als beim folio zu
erkranken deswegen ist diese impfung
auch nicht nur auf dem markt genauso wie
die keuchhusten ganze zeit ganz kämpfen
die nicht nur auf dem markt das weil sie
mehr nebenwirkungen hat als die jetzt
verfügbare immer noch mal die agenda ist
ich bin jahrgang 160 mein bruder ist ein
jahr jünger als ich der ist wird vier
oder fünf jahren an masern erkrankt der
damals gesagt ich solle mit ihm spielen
möglichst nahe kommen damit ich mich bei
ihm anstecken ist dann auch passiert ich
habe dann auch masern bekommen
dadurch sind wir beide wohl immunisiert
diese form mit mit mit
krankheitserregern umzugehen also nicht
das sagen klinisch zu verhindern durch
eine impfung ist die sinnvoller ist die
weniger sinnvoll gerade bei kindern ist
die masern erkrankungen ja
offensichtlich nicht so gefährlich dass
man sozusagen damit besser eine
resistenz gegen keime entwickelt das
könnte man so denken würde dass
schildern aber dann muss man ja
voraussetzen dass masern nur eine
harmlose krankheit sind die stars auf
dem terrain potenziell lebensgefährlich
und sehr komplikationsrate krankheit wir
haben kann ich berichten
haben halt weltweit große erfassung
dieser erkrankung und wissen ganz genau
wie viel komplikationen die masern haben
können in der dritten welt ist man
weiterhin eine sehr hohe ursache für
todesfälle und wir brauchen halt
masernimpfung um das zu verhindern und
in unserer ersten welt waren masern
früher auch eine hohe ursache für tolles
für tote kinder und auch erwachsene wenn
sie als kind die tour nicht hatten und
deswegen haben wir medizinischen
fortschritt gebraucht um gegen diese
krankheit zu verhindern
diese impfungen wie alle anderen
impfungen sind irgendwann
wissenschaftlich entwickelt worden weil
wir diese krankheiten besiegen wollten
und ich finde wir entfernen uns von
diesem dieser vorstellung dass das
gemacht wird um die menschen zu nutzen
all diese entwicklungen haben
stattgefunden wie andere
wissenschaftliche fortschritt
untersuchungen ja auch um den menschen
zu nutzen
das ist nicht primär pharma interesse
sondern erstmal im humanistischen
interesse gesundheit zu vermehren und
krankheit und tod zu verhindern
aber da will ich gar nicht einmal ein
haken das ist ja man das nicht so
vielleicht auch etwas zu einfach
schildert ist die der vorbehalt gegen
impfungen überhaupt gegen schulmedizin
wird ja unter anderem dadurch gespeist
dass man der pharmaindustrie in unserem
land nicht so richtig traut fragen
entscheiden
ich frage sie können gerne ich würde
gerne aber das gespräch auf diesen
aspekt bringt sie können sich dazu gerne
noch verkürzen als erstes wenn sie
gestatten
ancilla die fahrbahn ist es bei uns
bekannt dass geht's nicht ums impfen
vor allen dingen dass sie eine sehr
intensive lobbyarbeit betreibt die ja
durchaus auch kritikwürdig ist liefert
die da nicht auch den stoff dafür dass
man ihr gegenüber so kritisch
argumentiert auch so kritisch gegenüber
tritt dass man sagt also eigentlich ist
es ja in erster linie auch ein interesse
der pharmaindustrie dass möglichst viele
impfstoffe die darauf halte sind dann
verkauft werden
ich glaube nicht dass
dass die das allgemeine die die
allgemeine sicherlich auch kritische
herangehensweise an schulmedizin ja auch
die auseinandersetzung von von eltern
mit der frage schulmedizin oder
homöopathie und homöopathie es gibt auch
viele die zum kinderarzt gehen und zum
homöopathen gehen dieser gegensatz ist
ja gar nicht mehr so stark vorhanden
sondern eltern sind sehr viel und auch
überhaupt die patienten sind sehr viel
selbstbewusster geworden wollen
informationen haben wollen transparenz
haben über das was mit ihrer gesundheit
geschieht auch über die fragen von
pharmaindustrie und von medikamenten und
von zusammenwirken von medikamenten die
ja was ja auch häufig ein problem ist
dass das zusammenwirken
unterschiedlicher verschiedener
medikamente nicht richtig und
ausreichend erforscht oder informiert
ist aber beim thema impfen geht es um
ich weiß nicht was eine masernimpfung
heute kostet 35 euro oder impfstoffen 35
euro dann schaue ich glaube das ist bei
solchen fragen auch bei der
pharmaindustrie nicht um die frage des
ertrages geht da gibt es ganz andere
medikamente und ganz andere sachverhalte
wo das wo man das vielleicht
unterstellen kann sondern dass
entscheidend ist doch dass auch heute
noch in der dritten welt eine große zahl
der kinder die an masern erkrankten
sterben
die frage war ja der pharmaindustrie
etwas zu sagen glücklich gegenübersteht
ist nicht nur im bereich des impfen
sondern eben wie sie sonst auch agiert
dass dieser basis auch dieser kritischen
einstellung durch ihr verhalten auch
vorschub leistet der eindruck der hier
entsteht als die hälfte der bevölkerung
ist für das impfen und die hälfte die
andere hälfte der bevölkerung des
gegners irgendwann also ganze ist es ja
mein gott sei dank und 75 prozent findet
sogar für die impfpflicht also die die
zahl derer die sich mit dieser frage
auseinandergesetzt haben ist sehr hoch
und eine überwiegende mehrheit der
gesellschaft ist für verbindliches
impfen in unterschiedlichen formen sei
es beim bevor man in die kita geht in
die schule geht oder eine allgemeine
impfpflicht darüber wird ja derzeit ich
an unterschiedlichen stellen diskutiert
die wir haben derzeit ich beim thema
masern vor
ein problem zwischen denen die 1970
geboren sind und jünger sind wir sehen
das auch an den erkrankungen
dort ist der impfschutz sehr gering und
das ist die gruppe wo wir so große
impflücken feststellen dass wir das da
nach impfung notwendig ist weil die vor
allem die überträger auch sind für ihre
kinder und für diejenigen die immun
geschwächt sind und die lassen sich
jetzt in dieser diskussion ja
gottseidank intensiv informieren von
ihren ärzten schauen ihre impfpässe und
fragen ihren arzt und lassen sich dann
impfen um ihre kinder zu schützen aber
natürlich auch sich selbst zu schützen
und das ist völlig richtig weil wir
müssen keine verhältnisse wie in der
dritten welt haben das können wir in
deutschland verhindern
wir wissen inzwischen baum früher bei
uns die masern sterblichkeit so hoch war
also ein aspekt zumindest kennen wir
zumindest die whu kennt diesen aspekt
seit jahrzehnten propagiert die whu bei
schweren verläufen hoch dosierte vitamin
a infusion
das heißt man hat festgestellt in
studien
ich habe auf meiner webseite im
kritik.de eine menge studien dazu auf in
einem aktuellen artikel kann man
nachlesen kann alles verlinkt es gibt
studien die einen zusammenhang zeigen
zwischen schweren verläufen und vitamin
a mangel vitamin a gewinnt erzeugt
organismus selber durch frisches gemüse
karotten zum beispiel wer hungert hat
natürlich nicht genügend vitamin a
und dann sind dann auch die die verläufe
entsprechen das heißt die frage ist das
kind ich dass sie ihrem bett gestorben
jetzt tote also das ist oder das mit
ritalin behandelt oder nicht ist das
wissen der whu in deutschland beim
robert-koch-institut bundesligen behörde
angekommen bei ihnen bei der stiko
angekommen bei ihnen berlin angekommen
oder nicht die studien sind im internet
verfügbar die sind verlinkt auf meiner
webseite
aber die frage ist dass in ländern mit
mangelerscheinungen bei kindern die
masern und auch andere erkrankungen sehr
viel härter verlaufen oft auch tödlich
ist ja eine
lebensumständen zu tun ja wenn wenn wenn
ich als vater weiß mein kind ist gesund
ernährt dann habe ich mal nur ein
bruchteil der angst
berechtigterweise wenn ich außerdem weiß
wir hatten auch studien die bei der
stiko immer noch nicht angekommen sind
wenn ich außerdem weiß dass das
künstliche senken von fieber die
sterblichkeit das sterblichkeitsrisiko
drastisch erhöht ja dann frage ich mich
was ist mit dem kind was hier in berlin
leider gestorben ist wurde damals das
fieber gesenkt ist dieser studien diese
studien bei ihnen noch nicht angekommen
natürlich ist das angekommen ich muss
aber auch die aufgabe der stiko noch mal
klarstellen wir sind dazu da impf
empfehlungen abzugeben und keine
behandlungsempfehlung miteinbeziehen
schulde auch das tun wir regelmäßig wir
überprüfen alle unsere empfehlung
regelmäßig nach sehr hohen
standardisierten kriterien die vielen in
der welt geachteten kriterien
standhalten
das mit der vitamin a hat zum beispiel
die amerikanische kinder kinder hat sie
dazu bewogen das jetzt auch in ihrer
therapie empfehlung zu übernehmen aber
dennoch wir wissen auch dass masern
immer noch potenziell tödlich sein
können und auch die eltern sollten das
wissen und erfahren und sollten dann
auch daraus ihre schlüsse ziehen auch in
deutschland sind die masern immer noch
potenziell oder im gegebenen fall sitzt
ja warum sollen
warum wollen sie unbedingt impfen warum
wollt ihr alle dass wir unsere kinder
unbedingt impfen wenn es alternativen
geben da auch geschützt werden durch
pferden schutz das ist eine behauptung
da habe ich noch keine beweise für
gefunden auch gleich noch mal erklären
95 prozent müssen und seien damit diese
damit eine der ausbruch einer epidemie
einigermaßen wirtschaft wirksam
verhindert werden kann es gibt ja auch
immer die gegenposition zu sagen wenn
jetzt ein teil der kinder oder überhaupt
der bevölkerung nicht geimpftes gegen
masern
dann sind diejenigen die ja zum beispiel
nicht gegen masern geimpft werden können
weil sie geschwächtes immunsystem haben
eine andere krankheit dem schutzlos
ausgeliefert man wird das sozusagen
würden die nicht geimpften dann die
besonders schutzbedürftigen oder
empfindlichen anstecken was sagen sie zu
dieser argumentation kann so allgemein
nicht über einen kamm scheren es kommt
ganz darauf an ich stelle jedenfalls
fest was ich eben schon sagte dass man
sich nicht feststellen kann dass kinder
die nicht geimpft werden aber vernünftig
und nicht unterdrücken therapiert werden
dass die ein sehr starkes immunsystem
aufbauen es gab auch forschungen im raum
horb a tec hospital in london mit marie
tyler die hat diphtherie numm in
homöopathischen dosen verabreicht und
hat dann den täter im blut gemessen der
antikörper und der war erhöht wenn eine
ganze weile also es gibt auch andere
methoden einen solchen impfschutz
herzustellen dass es bekannt dass ist
erforscht in indien von diversen
doktoren in entsprechenden studien
veröffentlicht aber das wird hier nicht
zur kenntnis genommen es gibt hier nur
eine möglichkeit und das ist eben die
klassische impfung alles andere wird gar
nicht rezipiert die der vorwurf
wiederhole noch mal gegen diejenigen die
ihre kinder zum beispiel nicht impfen
lassen heißt ja damit könnten dann
andere kinder angesteckt werden wenn
damals ein ausbrechen nur diese anderen
kinder wenn die geimpften sind sie
eigentlich immun gegen masern welche
logik steckt dahin haben wir die flüge
impft
erstens ich bin kein mediziner ein
homöopath in und einen arzt der hier
sitzen sie sind glaube ich von hause aus
programmierer also ich erlaube mir nicht
ich bin auch nicht arzt sondern ich
frage 1 1 gegen frage nach der
argumentation frage ein fachmann wie er
mir was welche empfehlungen ergibt und
die ständige impfkommission ist für mich
als verantwortungsvoller vater ist es
für mich eine empfehlung der ich folge
die argumentation die ja zurecht
geäußert wird ist dass die linien die
nicht geimpft sind und ein masern
erkranken
diejenigen die ein und die krankheit
vielleicht auch gesund überleben gar
keine frage die kita erzieherin
beispielsweise die das kind war sehr
früh eingeschult sehr früh in die kita
haben und noch nicht den vollständigen
impfschutz aufbauen konnte dass sie
dieses kind ein
und dieses kind möglicherweise eine ent
sehr schwere erkrankung hat mit
folgeschäden oder diese kinder
kindergärtnerin hat damit potenziell
dieses leben gefährdet oder entschieden
entschieden beeinträchtigt und das ist
natürlich ein
das ist natürlich eine art weil sie
nicht geimpft ist das ist liegt auf der
hand und das ist auch der richtige grund
warum wir darüber diskutieren dass
medizinisches personal in krankenhäusern
geschützt sein soll damit es nicht auf
menschen die eine immunschwäche haben
sich das übertragen haben doch die
krankheit trotzdem bekommen was ist denn
herr mitbringen sie was durcheinander
dass die 17 prozent der geimpften kann
in bestimmten ausbruchs situationen wird
geprüft wie viele der erkrankten waren
geimpft und langen ball nicht im prozent
der nasa waren von den erkrankten in
einigen schulen auch mal 17 games das
heißt aber nicht dass 17 prozent der
geimpften erkranken das ist ein ganz
großer trugschluss
angenommen sie haben 100 prozent geimpft
wir wissen aber dass die impfung 05
versager haben und es kommt zu kontakt
mit masern an wenn sie auch murat wären
sie auch ein paar erkrankte haben aber
die sind dann alle geimpft und die frage
war ja vielleicht sollten wir noch mal
das unglaublich auch gefordert werden
pflicht ist das eine eine sinnvolle
maßnahme als ultima ratio also wir als
berufsverband der kinderärzte den ich ja
auch vertrete kinder und jugendärzte wir
sind schon auf das gespann auf dem
standpunkt dass für eine verpflichtung
brauchen
ich würde das müssen differenzieren ich
glaube wir brauchen eine verpflichtung
von kita eintritt aus ähnlichen gründen
wie hat ja dass gerade gesagt hat auch
für die dort arbeiten natürlich dass für
die auch für arztpraxen oder mein
personal musste regelmäßig den
impfschutz nachweisen wenn es neu
eingetreten ist das ist verantwortlich
auch influenza in form macht sinn im
personal durchgeführt auch wenn die
wirksamkeit nicht mit der masse an ihn
verglichen werden kann
aber halt wir müssen halt dazu kommen
dass halt wie reinhören verpflichtung
grad haben vor eintritt in eine kita vor
allen dingen weil wir so viele 3 also
unter dreijährigen betreuung in den
kitas heutzutage haben wo kinder auch
sind die noch nicht geimpft werden
durften oder konten oder wo auch die
eltern die impfung ablehnen die dann hat
die jünger sie sind ein viel größeres
risiko an schweren komplikationen und
schweren
zwischen spätkomplikationen haben und um
diesen personenkreis der fall
einjährigen weil sie die unter eingang
auch die ein bis zwei jahre das ist eine
folge der massenimpfungen eines
schlechten massenimpfungen der
schlechten durchimpfungsquote es ist
völliger schlechten massenimpfung der
schläger im projekt sei heutzutage
früher war das ja nicht so dass
säuglinge die masern gekriegt haben ja
die bahn durch den nestschutz da der
mutter geschützt
ja heutzutage bekommen soll klinge die
masern und erleiden schwer zum teil
schwere komplikationen
das ist das müssen sie auch ehrlich
zugeben eine folge der massenimpfung
weil nämlich die geimpften mütter diesen
netz schutz nicht mehr das ordentlich
warm da haben sie völlig recht deswegen
müssen wir noch diskutieren wie wir mit
den großen impflücken umgehen die wir
schließen müssen um dieses phänomen
verhindern zu können aber generell ist
die anzahl dieser schweren erkrankung
durch die impfung deutlich
zurückgegangen
aber jeder einzelne fall ist einer zu
viel und den können wir verhindern dafür
dass die eltern sich irgendwo sehr teuer
sagt in denen die säuglinge keinen
nestschutz krieg direkt mal durchgemacht
hätten gebe es das problem gar nicht die
haben die lebenslange immunität und
dabei wurde durch die spanien verhindert
das heißt sowie die 60er jahre dem
risiko der hunger das teilen zu großen
marken todesfällen wollen sie das
wirklich aus dass nur die impfungen an
dieser entwicklung teilhaben straße
gewiesen haben sie auch angeführt dass
die entwicklungsländer im ins
insbesondere durch die schlechte
ernährungslage in diese missliche lage
kommen dass so viele tote an diesen doch
relativ einfachen infektionskrankheiten
sterben diese situation ist ja nun
überhaupt nicht mehr gegeben und das
muss man als unterschied auch mal da
haben wir jedes jahr todesfälle weniger
haben wir aber auch eine ganz wichtige
information also die masernimpfung ist
er 1973 eingeführt worden in deutschland
die sterblichkeit ist bis 1972 als vor
einführung der masernimpfung verglichen
mit 1900 auf weniger als ein prozent
gefallen da gab es noch keine impfung
sie wissen aber was ein prozent bedauert
weniger fällen würden ein ex tote
bedeuten
das kann bedeuten muss nicht kann
bedeuten dass die massenimpfung auf
einen längst fahrenden epidemiologischen
zug
aufgesprungen ist und den letzten rest
beanspruchungen jetzt die impfexperten
für die impfung kann man jetzt aber gar
nicht mal so sagen was man sagen kann
ist dass die sterblichkeit vorher völlig
unabhängig von der impfung ist in berlin
geboren werden alle die masern durch
leben und dass davon ein prozent stirbt
das waren nicht wir ja eine lösung für
alle ein gott in deutschland die gebirge
haben wollen die das recht haben sich zu
informieren und ihre schlüsse daraus zu
ziehen eben keine lösung für alle
sondern individuelle lösungen gut
solange es die impfpflicht gibt kann das
auch jeder noch selbst entscheiden die
meinung sind ja hier ziemlich hart
aufeinander geplant ich bedanke mich
dass sie da waren 45 minuten ist auch
eine relativ kurze zeit ein komplexes
thema zu diskutieren allerdings bedürfte
es ja auch sehr viele vielen dank dass
sie hier waren und bleiben sie bei
phoenix